-We are back, everybody.
John Cena is here with us
in studio!
-Seven live audience members.
-From New York City.
Studio 6A at 30 Rock.
I'm so happy you're here.
Your fans want to hear about it.
I want to hear about
"Fast 9."
I know -- Yeah, I know.
This is --
We were talking about it,
and you were like,
"Oh, get ready, man. The stunts
on this is just insanity."
-Well, that's the thing.
I think, so "Fast 9,"
very similar to BTS, they have
this global fanbase.
Because they've been making
these movies for 20 years.
-Sure.
-So it's been
a legacy project, you know?
And the newest installment --
like, everybody knows "Fast"
is gonna kill it
when it comes to action.
The thing I love about "Fast 9"
is people are gonna see it
weave that legacy together.
And it's not --
You know, it's not merely
what is "Fast"
gonna do next for action.
It is action
on the edge of your seat,
but story, if you're
a fan of the franchise,
like, you get questions
answered,
you get new questions
you develop.
Like, it's another foothold
to the narrative,
which that's the stuff
that I love.
-Were you nervous
walking onto set?
Because hey all know each other
for years.
-Normally, no.
Normally, it's a job
and movies
are kind of like summer camp
where you meet people
for the first time
and then you establish
relationships
and then you move on.
"Fast" is different
because literally
it's been 20 years
in the making.
So walking in the set of "Fast"
was similar to walking into
the WWE locker room.
You have guys --
and men and women
who risk their lives
for a living,
and have curated this experience
that they're very proud of.
So when we get a newcomer
to walk in,
like, you can't help it
but like,
"Man, I hope this person
works out
because I'm killing myself
for this."
-It's my new brother-in-law.
-Everybody --
When I'm like -- And I'm
geeked out on "Fast,"
so I'm looking at like
Dom Toretto,
I'm looking at him going,
"Oh, my God."
And it's like this,
it's like...
Dude, it's like the Vin look,
like...
-[ Laughing ]
-And not just him, bro.
Everybody.
Everybody was like, "Yo."
-They know how to play, yeah.
-"What's up with the new kid?"
And I've never --
Like, I felt just as much
pressure as my first month
on the road in WWE.
But what I love about
the "Fast" family
is that as soon as they see that
you're a fan of the franchise,
that your intention
is for the family,
bro, they take you in,
and it really is --
Like, they talk so much
about family.
And like, I owe so much to Vin
for not only allowing me
to be in the movie,
but making me better
as a performer.
But it's a family.
It's weird to say.
-You get close.
-It's also the camaraderie
of WWE.
Like, once you're in,
you're in.
-Yeah, and you help each other.
-And, man, it was awesome.
I had a blast filming that one.
Not only do you do
crazy stuff, but like --
-We got a picture of some
stunt you were doing.
They sent us a photo of you,
one scene in the movie.
This is exclusive to our show.
This is you like zip lining
over Edinburgh.
-Yeah.
-I kind of took that place over
for a few days.
-Are you good with heights?
-No, no, not at all.
[ Laughter ]
So that was the toughest
thing about "Fast,"
is like you gotta do this
crazy [bleep],
but you have to look like
it doesn't affect you.
-Yeah.
-And I --
Like, if they close up
and HD that,
you would see a puddle
in my pants.
[ Laughter ]
I done peed myself but I have to
look like it's nothing.
Whoosh! All right, here we go!
-Yeah.
So you'll see in the movie,
I look pretty tough.
But I had already peed myself
a few times.
-Okay, yeah, I would have
freaked out,
because I went zip lining
with Tariq in Puerto Rico.
And...
[ Laughter ]
-You don't look afraid.
-Here's me and Tariq.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Yeah.
And that's my -- that's my...
[ Laughter ]
-If it's any consolation,
that's how I felt
on the inside.
-Yeah.
This was my audition
for "Fast 9," they didn't --
-We're just going to go
in another direction.
Just gonna go another way.
Love you. Love you.
-Jimmy, we love you.
-We're just gonna
go another way.
-You're my favorite,
we're just gonna go in
a different direction.
[ Laughs ] And then
"Suicide Squad."
-Yep.
-Come on.
-You're playing Peacemaker.
People are freaking out.
Even --
There's nothing even
in the trailer,
just a list of names, and
people are like, "What?!"
-I think the most important
thing as far as
"The Suicide Squad" is concerned
is the name James Gunn.
And people know James and his
passion to tell the story,
his passion to weave a narrative
and develop characters
you care about.
A perfect template for that
is "Guardians."
As just a general moviegoer
I knew nothing about
"Guardians," but five minutes
into the movie
I loved the characters.
And that's what he does
so well.
-Are they spinning off
your character already
into like a --
I heard like a show?
-Mm, yes. Noes. Yes. Yes.
-Okay, I was like, wait --
-I mean, this is also,
you know,
you try do the best you can
with every opportunity.
I really loved "Suicide Squad"
and got along great with James.
I was like, "Hey, man,
we should do this again."
He's like, "Yeah,
Pretty soon it was like, "Yo,
wanna do a show for HBO Max?"
I was like, "What? Yes."
-This is fantastic
having an in-studio guest
because I'm getting
all these exclusives.
You're just, like,
dropping bombs.
It's fantastic, I love it.
-So I was down for a bit,
but now that we're
filming again,
I'll be -- I'm currently
in production with
a cool comedy called
"Vacation Friends."
We just went back to work,
and it's very much like this.
It's very protected
and very safe.
-Safe.
-Telling jokes
and come here to talk to you
and then go back
and tell some jokes.
-Yeah, back to work.
-Can we talk about
"Fast Friends: Elbow Grease"?
-I would love to.
-Or as I call them,
bow -- "Elbow Grease:
Fast Friends."
This one, this is
your third one,
and I have the other two.
I read them to my daughters.
I love the messages
in all of these.
But this one, there's a new
character,
it's a motorcycle.
-Yes, there's an electric
motorcycle called Chopper,
and she's very skilled.
-Yes.
-She is very skilled.
-She is.
-That's very important.
So, um,
with the "Elbow Grease" books,
I have a very young audience
at WWE,
a lot of kids,
lot of families,
and as my in-ring career
is not as --
it's not as active --
it's not over,
but it's not as active --
I wanted to continue
to send messaging
to those younger viewers
because so many times
parents will be like,
"Hey, your 'never give up'
words have helped
my son or daughter."
Okay, so I created
a children's book series
that is fun and bright
and colorful
and about monster trucks.
So first and foremost,
it's a fun read.
-Yeah.
-And then there's some
underlying stuff in there
about never giving up.
And because it was a success,
we got to do another book.
The second book is about
the value of teamwork,
and this third book
is about being comfortable
in your own skin,
facing insecurities,
jealousy, not judging a book
by its cover, so to speak,
not being judgmental.
But only if you choose it.
You can also read the book
and be like,
"It's a cool motorcycle
with cool monster trucks."
-Monster trucks, yeah,
exactly.
-I think that's really
important
'cause I don't want to hit
anybody over the head
with messaging, I want them
to enjoy the book.
And if they want to take
something away from it,
they can.
-It's up to you, yeah.
I love it. "Elbow Grease:
Fast Friends"
is out right now.
John, every time
you've been here, gosh,
we've done almost every
single sketch together.
-We hit each other with fish
last time.
-Last time we -- gosh!
[ Laughter ]
-It's like you're not even
trying anymore.
Hey, fish slap!
What's that technical
game about, Jimmy?
-That was a classic.
-What could that ever be about?
-Fish slap was -- yeah.
-I don't even have to
explain the rules of fish slap.
-You don't.
-No.
We should do -- by the way,
we should do a sitcom together.
Let's stop fooling around.
-Or should we do like
a buddy cop movie?
-Oh, yeah.
Like two detectives.
"Two Dicks."
-Two --
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so everyone that makes
movies just heard that.
-Come on!
-That idea is out
there in the universe.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Fallon as a dick!
[ Laughter ]
John Cena as another dick.
-Hello, ma'am. Yeah. Yeah.
"You didn't knock!"
"I can knock and I can ring
the doorbell."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Uh...
Uh, we have a new game
called...
[ Laughing ]
-We have a new game
called Sink the Ship.
-Toss -- it's called
Toss it Over.
You ready to play
when we come back?
-Yes, I am.
Of course I will.
[ Laughter ]
-Not just the name of the game.
John and I are doing something
fun after the break.
Stick around.